how do you direct a kissing scene I know
there's a lot more than kissing that
just goes on and on the horizon but yeah
but I think it goes with the chemistry
and the trust that they have for each
other
and then because in general there's
always music so when I'm filming them
I'm like now you can direct them like
now you stay apart and slowly come back
together and slowly but you don't touch
you don't kiss you just you really want
each other but you still hold there's
like a wall between do but there's a big
tension then you direct them like that
and then you just you see them acting
live what you're doing and then it's
just like now kissing the most
passionate way and then it goes super
fast and and do it so so that's what the
beauty of just trust with each other for
them to just go and be comfortable with
them and then so that's why Tyler
insanity just click that chemistry
worked perfectly and but yet you just
you just I don't know I guess you have
to be a little bit pervert and just go
with it and just create your fantasy of
just like this is what you're gonna do
and you just direct the scene live and
good actor is they're gonna listen too
well and they're gonna they're gonna be
good at the reacting and I think that's
the most magical way to they need to be
ready life to go in any kind of
direction I can pull them is it almost
like choreographing and dance
yeah a little bit but for example
there's a scene with whatever I don't
want to tell him but there's a sign slow
motion and they're kissing and I love
there's a thing for them up the best
advice I can see at least for me what
I'm doing is that there's a scene I give
them a circle of ideas this is the
circle the bubble that you're going in
this is the world this is the scene and
then in that scene I want you to go in
that environment for is about that mood
and then in that mood you go and then
I'll be there shooting for six seven
minutes and just going around around you
and then if there's something missing
I'm gonna give you tips
okay now kiss more touches hair grab his
face that but I'm always shooting for 67
minutes it's a long take and but I don't
want to cut that I want to kill that
moment so will forgive all the waterfall
scene it was a good whatever three four
minutes
having them and then again when you let
it roll there's at one point to win it's
flapping in the hair everything is just
beautiful and then we go into the
waterfall even the waterfall sex scene
it was one take five minutes and I just
let it roll and then in dat thing I cut
cut zoom or stuff like that but I just I
just went they know what the actor knows
when it's time to be passionate when
it's time to be that's I that style of
kiss or if it's a sex scene it needs to
be pure passion and rough and a little
bit animalistic then they know that but
then if they're gonna it's me to just
drive the pedal more or less and stuff
like that
and in some time they don't like me
talking
it's like Pascal shut up let me do my
thing and that's great and sometimes
sometimes we have to do it more takes
but I'll let them do that but sometimes
it's just missing I'm just getting into
a little bit of an action just to
nourish the single well for some of the
other scenes they were more animalistic
there was a lot of passion or many other
emotions going on so how are you
injecting yourself into those scenes and
how much do you stand back because I
know you know they would say oh they we
had a closed set well you only had three
people it's pretty much a closed set
from the beginning but but still there
were some pretty intense scenes there
that how how did you make it more
comfortable for them or maybe that's not
the point that's not the point for me
I'm like I'm there I'm in your face and
I'm just there to capture a moment
your job is don't think about me be
there in the moment and of course I'll
try not to be distracting to them but at
the same time I'm there to just capture
that and I love to shoot everything
inhaled when it's just in your face raw
close-up and be ready for that you know
you you cannot think about the camera
otherwise you're not gonna be in the
scene but each scene
I've each seen a very if it's passion
love tender animalistic it's always the
same process I didn't do anything
differently it's always there's a music
and I'm just there in your face and I
just into a little bit of this little
bit than that just to give them
direction but the goal is to really
explain this thing before the movie that
you're going
and then you create this kind of an arc
you listen like I said you it's like a
dance you know you just score a graph or
a little bit and you just said you're
gonna start here then you're gonna go
there and you're gonna go there and
finish with this and then you shoot for
five minutes and then you do it maybe
two three times and you just edit
through that so the goal is just to lift
the lid then live and do their stuff and
if you have to come come because a lot
of directors just left to talk talk all
the time shut up sometime just go and
let them create you know let them have
fun for you be a judge just just be a
spectator and just after that when it's
done it was great now it's amazing just
lets do it because now I think it was
around that part was just missing this
so we do the whole thing again and
fixing that just little part I'm not a
believer of just let screen shoot just
that little part it's not the same magic
so I love to just I love to shoot a long
time so so even some of the more intense
sex scenes are you're treating them the
same as any other scene where they're
just having dialogue in some sense yeah
that what you mean okay it's no
different for you no different
I don't know I don't want to be cold but
it's so it's I don't know if scene is a
scene you know and of course you have to
respect what they're doing but there's
more scene that I'm gonna be more vocal
about it while doing it okay now you go
I want you to kiss the data but when
it's something more aggressive for
example like there's a scene near the
end and that's when it's just like I
shut up completely and I let them be in
there and after that I'm just like wow
nice amazing and they okay let's do it
again then I can just say go and tweak
that a little bit and but no more than
sometime it's fine for some of the scene
to just do it alone do it again and
again to to tore down the actor a little
bit so that it can be more vulnerable
more not less fresh you know I mean so
some see some stuff some of this things
sometime needs to be some principal it
needs to be they need to feel tired then
you cannot really fake tiredness so
let's do a couple of takes so that they
can really feel like they look at me
do you got it now and I'm like one more
and then you then maybe that take is
gonna be a big different because now
they're tired and you can feel just the
way their hair our place are just in
their face the emotion the energy is
you can see them now they are in the
right state of mind to do that little
moment that you're trying to get if you
force something is not gonna work
you